- [Keith] We're going to see the moose,
the moose, the moose.
We're going to see the
moose, the moose today!
- See, Zach's the lynx, I think.
And then, Keith's the moose.
And then, Ned, you're a brown bear.
And I'm a tundra wolf.
- [Ned] I guess that makes sense.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
Tundra wolf.
- I'm the moose?
(upbeat music)
- Welcome to our beautiful Alaska getaway!
(plane engine)
- It's eight o'clock, and already Alaska
is bubbling with excitement!
It's like he can't not look majestic.
- That thing can fuck you up.
- Now we're going an a
nature adventure today...
If we don't get blown away.
- What kind of animal is this?
- [Ned] They usually don't have Ned.
- [Zach] Found it right here.
- Really?
We're here in Alaska filming
a very special secret video.
- We have more days here
than we have things to do.
Luckily, we've got a game.
- We have now embarked on foot
for our morning moose hunt.
It's a cold, hard moose butt.
Whoa!
Okay we're leaving, bye-bye!
No more chain link fences will protect us.
We are going out into the wild.
The other three guys are asleep.
They did karaoke.
- Fuck! I'm like a bird! I only fly away!
- (inaudible)
- ♪Part of that world♪
- Where do I go, there's no end!
- [Ned] Here's where we go
for the end of the world.
- This is like when the character goes
into the forbidden woods.
Florida man gets mauled
by a moose in Alaska
trying to take a picture of it.
(ominous music)
Oh, that's not tiny.
I don't know if he sees us.
Oh God he sees us, he
definitely sees us now.
He knows we're vlogging.
(screaming)
- I'm going to surprise
the rest of the guys.
I got them some coffees. Let's see.
- [Keith] Ned!
- [Ned] Good morning!
- Stop it!
- [Ned] We're in Alaska!
Eugene wake up!
- No, I don't wanna.
- I'm Zach. I'm weak.
(laughter)
- Hey, what do you guys
wanna do today, huh?
- Ow!
- [Ned] This is a game that
Buzzfeed made, let's play it.
- [Keith] And awkward
party game by Buzz Fuzz.
- This is a game called "Social
Sabotage", the way it works
is one person draws a "where"
card like, "send a man..."
and then the other players have
to pick one of their cards.
So you might have to send a man,
"I've always admired your calf muscles."
- So this is like hypothetical texting?
- Every one is different,
a lot of these are posted
on your Facebook or on your Instagram--
- And if the person does
it, they get a point.
Boom, let's play.
- Send a woman
(guys laughing)
- Oh, I got it, Keith
you're gonna pick mine.
- So should I send a woman
"my breath smells like beef jerky"?
Should I send a woman a video
of you in the bathroom
pointing out all the features?
Or, a photo of you kissing
your own reflection?
That is, that is perfect to a T!
- Dammit!
- I'm doing it.
- [Zach] Wow, this is hot.
Okay, that's enough.
- What? I like me.
- Can we go see a moose now?
We have arrived at the
Nature Conservation Center.
We're gonna see some animals.
("Old McDonald Had a Farm" playing)
- So they aren't married, it's
just sort of a free-for-all.
- It's a free-for-all, big salmon orgy.
They die for love.
- Wow, they just mix all
of their seed together.
- Sounds like your
Wednesday date nights, Ned.
- It is not like my
Wednesday date nights, Zach.
- Will you quit it?
Everyone can see the bears now,
but I'd like to think that the bear and me
had a special time when
no one else was there.
Susan Sarandon, I love your work,
can I get an autograph?
When a bear comes here,
they just must crush salmon.
Like, this is so easy.
They're just everywhere.
- Yeah, and that's why
our brown bear are bigger.
- [Eugene] Yeah.
(laughter)
- This is all bear-y interesting.
(Eugene dry laughing)
- [Zach] Those are big deer.
- Are they expensive, yeah
they're a lot of dough.
- Water's so silty because
it's full of glacial till.
- That gets my sill of approval.
- Eugene there's something I've been
meaning to talk to you about.
You know what, Alaska you later.
- You feeling horny?
- I don't think he heard you.
- Yeah this guy's buff...ello!
- I can bear-ly see him.
- [Zach] Hello, yes, big
fan. I love your work.
- Oh, these are elk?
- I don't associate with their elk.
- [Zach] Have we been getting
it wrong the whole time?
Oh dear.
Can I get an autograph?
Oh my God, you're
beautiful. You're beautiful.
So how's the phone that was dropped?
- [Ned] She dropped her
phone in, how embarrassing.
- [Zach] Em-bear-assing?
Where's that hot, hot whale action?
Whale, I think we're done here.
Bye, son!
- How many exes do you have Ned?
- I don't want to talk
about this, you guys.
- [Zach] Did I get a refuse to send an ex?
- Ned's not wife.
- [Ned] Come on.
- I use my ex's HBO Go password still.
- What?
- You can't do that when you're married!
(instrumental music)
- [Keith] Oh my God, is that an eagle?
- It's a bald eagle.
- It's a bald eagle, Keith.
- Wow. It's beautiful.
- Yeah.
- And then there's some
other owl over here?
(bird screech)
- That's majestic as fuck.
- [Eugene] I just ate a bunch
of oysters, rock and roll!
My older sister texts back, "fuck you".
Then my little sister texts
back, "Yeah, fuck you."
- [Keith] Wow.
- Family!
- [Keith] Family.
Whoa, what happened? What
just happened to you?
- I sneezed and I coughed. I snoughed.
- [Keith] That sounded like an animal.
- It started as I sneezed.
- Speaking of animals, I wonder
what they're up to right now.
Oh Snickers, you do not smell good.
(porcupine whining)
I'm sorry that I said you smell bad.
I didn't mean to hurt your feelings.
- [Eugene] Nice to know
even wild cats act just like cats.
- That fact that he wants nothing
to do with me makes me want him more.
- [Keith] These are real wolves.
- Are those meat cubes?
- Yeah, they're actually blood pops.
- [Ned] So, what are these cubes?
- Literally frozen chicken blood.
I made them earlier today.
- [Ned & Zach] You made them?
- [Girl] Yeah.
- [Zach] You little chef.
- [Keith] You're a chef.
- Do you guys want to get some gloves on?
- You can throw the last four.
- [Distorted Voice] Yes.
Yes.
- Oh my God.
- [Ned] Oh my God, we get to feed wolves!
Yeah, so what are blood pops made out of?
- The blood of your father.
- [Zach] We're gonna
break one of those rules.
- I'll do the inaugural blood cube.
Delicious, healthy, blood cubes.
Yeah!
- So boys, who's hungry?
- [Keith] (inaudible) that blood cube!
- What was your favorite
part about the blood cube?
- Oh, probably the cube.
- Can you sit?
The female took a little bit of it,
but he got a lick. He got a lick.
- Blood pops!
- Time to leave now.
- Oh that's my new buddy.
What's the name of the porcupine here?
- [Zach] Snickers.
- Snickers.
- Snickers, oh. Maybe I'll call him,
I'm gonna name you Porcupine.
- [Ned] Very creative.
This is the greatest day of my life.
So soft.
- So soft. Oh it's so soft, so soft.
- Whoa, hey!
This has been a vlog, thanks for the vlog,
(grunting)
You get it!
- [Keith] You get it, there's a bear.
- [Ned] Oh shit!
- [Eugene] On Dasher, Prancer,
Donner, Blitzen, Rudolph.
- Where's Chanta?
- [Keith] Chanta is dead.
- ♪I'm your biggest fan♪
- ♪Don't lead me his way♪
- ♪Something I were to feel with♪
- I don't know, there's
no end! I don't know!